[Music]
and back to school stripper news make it
rain submit by sleeping panda you
submitted before maybe sneezing happy as
you look for long tanka kinda looks like
a steep independent a kindergarten
headmaster has apologized after allowing
a pole dancer to perform on the school's
opening day that's time they're in a
panda suit I'm alright with it
yeah I'm saying that's the only way it's
acceptable I picture titties all out and
everything yeah I picture titties
tastefully covered oh it tastes week
with a panda fur it's getting our
tassels oh my God all these
kindergarteners are gonna call in the
playground and any sort of pole that
they see there between the same moves if
I'm the teacher when the teeth out read
France belongs to me I'm like but the
bottles were on guys email female
headmaster is this in the [ __ ] UK no
well [ __ ] is it what do you think I feel
like it's in South America it's weird
cuz it's the word as headmaster instead
of like a principal I'm going with here
I feel like it's in Latin America
guessing Japan no this actually happen
in Beijing in China what or in Shenzhen
to be exact I didn't think of China to
be a sexual type of yeah either
how are the strippers in China Ximena
I'm drawing a blank I don't even know
what a Chinese triple looks like you
guys remember though how in China they
would have strippers at funerals so this
all right he had the dad yeah I forgot
why I don't know lighten up the mood big
party like like to give like because her
friend loved strippers or so sure why I
don't I don't remember but they did have
it was it was like years ago but I mean
it wasn't just strippers attendant or
strippers perform they're all like
grinding on the casket and [ __ ]
that's good I wanna see Chinese grinding
video is blinding yeah so this at this
school this American writer who lives
there who takes his kids to these
kindergarten this kind of read him um he
said that when he arrived she was like
what the [ __ ] there's these like two
performers or just pulled dancing and
she was just so appalled he tweeted it
out and then these tweets went viral
they were like what the hell so then
that's when because of this going public
that's one finally like the school
responded and apologized and said that
the headmaster it would be I think
dismissed
I don't know headmaster at a sweet gig
for I'm gonna show you guys a video clip
of that the dad sokeep titled this um so
before our kids got out of kindergarten
for the summer there was ten days of
military activities and displays of
machine guns and mortars at the door now
the cool look welcomed them back with
the strip pulled dance on the flagpole
bearing the PRC flag she's gone nuts
wait wait so before this there was
machine guns and all that they let like
when they got out of school yeah this
last semester yeah there was like
machine guns and just all this military
action
ten days worth that's is crazy does that
mean like Joe malli in school military
come in with your [ __ ] with Jam this
is crazy they were let out of school
with military activities and then now
they're being welcomed back with pole
dancing here like their fire not to a
reason [ __ ] last semester the theme is
war this semester it's lust this
semester it's making money yeah yes so
here we go she's dancing on the flagpole
but who is the principal no
they're all waiting to be picked up the
children
like she's having fun at all oh my god I
would feel weird
wait this is kindergarten kindergarten
she's like really doing sexual [ __ ]
there's like four little girls in red
outfits watching well they're yeah they
had like drums at their feet Wow super
well these are three ages three to six
will they make it because there is a
difference between strippers and pole
dancers nice that's why we're calling
them pole dancers Oh she was definitely
dressed for the part there's nothing
wrong with pole dancing
no but she's huge actually she was
dressed now for the role you know saying
if it was more so so if we'd stripped
the sexuality out of pole dancing then
it's just acrobatics right the form of
acrobatics so if they left it that way
then I'd be fine with it but she was
like on all fours like [ __ ] swinging
her hair and I reading her hips a little
too much so I'm like all right that's
sexual now what if she had stage fright
and she forgot about her acrobatic moves
and surely remember the other ones and
these are the way at the pool jet the
improv implies out of her butt I have
you have said that they didn't pull the
cord or the plug on her yeah I think the
difference is like it's it's it's like a
Cirque show right like you got the
sexual ones like Zumanity even though
you're using rings and in acrobatics but
it's still very sexual versus like I
don't know a cop it's not that sexual
problem is she's together job yeah some
of the strip clubs I've been to if they
would have gotten some of those girls I
think that would have been not offensive
at all I think it would have actually
been probably just a demonstration of
some kind of pulled acrobatic technique
I was I was waiting for the moment where
she climbs up and does the thing where
they [ __ ] go upside down and spread
their leg and it's assuming I'm gonna be
like more wild like that like she's all
spinning and her [ __ ]
that was just a small portion we don't
know it could have been that hilarious
she wasn't getting any tips because the
[ __ ] didn't touch this right now if she
did those kids would have known to throw
money as everyone knows that they had
these ads around the school promoting
like pole dancing maybe the headmaster
got a really good deal that's what
that's what a lot of people are saying
they're like what did this headmaster
gonna cut or something like why why
would she accept this she thinking
that's ridiculous
you're gonna be [ __ ] kindergarten
pole dancing classes let me tighten
magic is this even hold the pole cuz
their hands are so small well they can
use pole gloves it is the kit balls
they make them smaller for kids yeah
it's like no the horse he pulls when
you're on the merry-go-round there's a
thicker than well those are the
adolescent oh you know you can hold on
right maybe well maybe where it is what
they do pull handles you suction cup
handles on the pole and then you can get
a little hand yes Elena the next week
this man he wrote the principal hung up
on my wife when she called after saying
it was international and good exercise
okay yeah for adults maybe even offered
three to six year old kids
the principal said that my wife had a
sexy voice and then after what she was
wearing
I love this school bed I love this
school yes the principal was saying like
she apologized to all the parents and
she's saying that she apologized to them
before like the school stepped in but
yeah she was just saying that she was
trying to show that the kid she was
trying to show the kids that there are
multiple types of dancing careers oh
Rudy
sorry kindergarten star myung yeah and
so like she's just there's already too
many doctors and lawyers and stuff so I
think it's good to provide another
alternative they should have said look
three out of every 100 of you will be
doing this
and then the next 15 to 16 years if
they're gonna do it they better do it
well right so inviting
professional dancers to kindergarten to
perform for the parents would liven up
the mood on the first day back for who
the dads or the kids right that's a lot
of people on on social media they were
saying they were like well I mean like a
lot of dads they were like well if this
was happening I would pick up my
daughter every single day from school on
time it works what works she that wasn't
her intent no so like what you're doing
is you have all these daughter is that
with the dads are coming late right but
the now with the pull-down sir the dads
are coming on time the kids it's for the
kids a system that geo it's called
supply chain management if you pay
attention you knows - I'm just pissed
that there was no passion in that dancer
I was like what kind of lazy [ __ ] is
this it was a too early in the morning
for her was 8:30 yeah she's just like oh
my god no that's cool what would have
been more passionate or her licking her
lips and [ __ ] I need some fire yeah I
mean like go all the way or just don't
do sexual [ __ ] at all you know like I
don't know I agree we live in a porn
world now yeah you have to really bring
it to the pole man don't be half don't
be like softcore because there's
children around you know like either go
super passionate and like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of that pole or just spin around
like like you're a ballerina you want
her to be a stripper or not a pole
dancer I need her I need her to go one
way or the other because if you watch
that video she was like she looked like
she was a sex slave or some [ __ ] and she
was mad at she was just like she was she
was forced into it dude like yeah that's
what I said she just got what if she was
what if it's like like that's not the
her career time there's no passion yeah
it's like it was that's what I felt like
I was sad why don't what job you're
given try to do your best that's what I
always was how was maybe she was like
this is not my usual crowd so she's not
like but she knows she's not gonna get
nervous she was passing it like I was
like wow dude yeah cuz our usual moves
like gets a certain reaction because you
know that crowd it's a different crowd
so like it's not getting the same
reaction shots to try different things I
think yeah but when you're a
professional dancer or performer you're
supposed to be on stage if there's no
bring the crowd at all and I think that
that's where she really must
I blame her frankly she was in her head
too much yep that dad wouldn't have
complained if she was really bringing
into that pole I think we all know that
that's true so the principal also said
that she did not think through the
contents of the performance duh
or maybe she wasn't given a proper
greenroom where she could you know get
into her acting space yeah maybe
did she get to pick the song yeah she
might he just walk straight from the car
straight to the pole and she'd have a
chance to prepare and rehearse her stuff
so true yeah she usually comes out to my
neck my back crack that's that song that
she's all he does but we're probably a
Chinese explicit version right what's up
words isn't what that be ho yeah so now
she's in trouble
good [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] head who
the Headmaster's in trouble or not that
not venison not the innocent dancing
right hey mister they should have hired
a better dancer dance I agree that
dancer is innocent she was just doing
her job the Headmaster's [ __ ] wild
she needs to go just doing her job right
just like the prison guards at Auschwitz
right Gio yep Wow no go ahead you see
you that's all you that's all you don't
throw it on her Wow why is your head
thinking of that [ __ ] white guy we
talked about that's horrible I never
think about that not once you don't
think about it why would you you should
because that really happened Gio oh you
want to go with me you want to go 12
rounds did it really happen and that is
a [ __ ] this swish you've been to bed
that is a home run
why do you make all the girls Christ
[Music]